[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute geht es weiter mit der plätzchen
bäckerei ich zeige euch heute wie man
aus einem teig ganz viele verschiedene
plätzchen zubereiten kann also wirklich
eine richtig große plätzchen vielfalt
dieser teig nennt sich mehr beteiligt
und es ist ein 12 3 beträgt denn ein
teil ist sogar zwei teile sind mutter
und drei teile sind mir könnt ihr euch
wirklich super merken und je nachdem wie
viel ihr backen wollt macht ihr ebenso
viel an menge also ich habe zwar
tatsächlich einen tag schon vorbereitet
und habe diese menge genommen das sind
nämlich 300 gramm zucker 600 gramm kalte
butter und 900 gramm mehl ihr könnt
dinkel oder weizen nehmen und als zusatz
nehme ich dann noch vanille extrakt und
eine prise salz also das sind so die
basis zutaten salz immer ganz wichtig
denn auch wenn es wirklich nur ein
viertel teelöffel ist bei der großen
menge jetzt ist es wirklich so dass salz
einfach nochmal dieses i-tüpfelchen an
geschmack bringt also wirklich so den
geschmack noch mal pusch vanille extrakt
nämlich beim basis zeigt aber wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel zimt kekse draus
machen will oder kaffee je nachdem was
es halte wird und der andere geschmack
das war die längst übertönen würde dann
spare ich natürlich meine electric also
da mache ich nicht rein muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen und jetzt ist eigentlich
nur ganz wichtig dass die butter ganz
kalt ist oder dass der teig eben auch
gleich lange gekühlt wird ihr könnt
jetzt hier zucker oder puderzucker nimmt
foto zucker ist halt eher so eine
kostenfrage also das bisschen teurer ihr
könnt auch den zucker im hochleistungs
mixa einfach selber vermahlen und dann
habt ihr puderzucker aber ich find's
einfach ganz gut den teig jetzt schnell
zusammen kneten entweder mit den händen
oder mit einem messer geht es auch
deswegen hieß der möglich früher auch
aktg oder eben einfach in der
küchenmaschine mit seinem flach hörer
oder auch mit einem knethaken von
handrührgerät also ihr habt wirklich
allerlei aktionen und jetzt gebe ich
hier die zutaten einfach alle rein und
wirklich nur ganz kurz verrühren bis
alles vermengt ist unter trike noch
schön kalt bleibt
[Musik]
pro tag jetzt wirklich groß nichts zu
beachten und das ist auch so ein teig
den könnte wirklich super einfach
legalisieren indem ihr einfach vegane
butter nehmt murat will sagen und
schleswig holstein
ja und was ich beim plätzchenbacken
immer beachtet weil ich ja wirklich wer
nicht mal backe dann auch recht viel
backe ich packe mir praktisch alle
zutaten alle vorräte auf dem tisch habe
dann alles griffbereit und dann könnt
ihr wirklich ganz ganz schnell alles
zubereiten so
und jetzt verrühren
[Musik]
und hier könnt ihr den teig jetzt
entweder hell zu bereiten so wie ich
oder ihr könnt auch eine schoko variante
machen und könnt einfach ein bisschen
mehr wegnehmen und cacau zu fügen also
back cacau ohne zucker ich weiß ich habe
früher immer charakter sagt pia spisak
studis
takaoka ja aber ich habe mich ungewohnt
weil mir meine zuschauer haben mich
verändert die hat mich immer ausgelacht
wenn ich kack abgesagt haben und dann
gesagt das heißt soll das heißt sonne
und dann kam es sowohl das kleine kind
und redet einfach hochdeutsche als die
mutter und die hat hama das ist heißt
cacau
da habt ihr mich verändert ich sage
nicht ich sage ich mal kaka oh ja da ist
weg die all das erlebt
die weselerin
und dann sagen die menschen hat sich
verändert sie sagte immer mit cacau dann
sag ich ja das war ihr
habt ihr hier einen schönen
geschmeidigen teig und es ist auch
wirklich ein teig der wunderbar ohne
auskommt
sehr sehr schön und jetzt ist wichtig
den zu kühlen ich würde jetzt nicht so
als rolle kühlen sondern einfach mal
halbieren dass er möglichst schnelle
auch kühlt schnell möglichst schnell
auch kills schön flach drücken und so
kann ich dir jetzt für ein bis zwei
stunden kühlen ihr könnten aber auch
gerne schon am tag vorher zu bereiten
und vorbereiten dann habt ihr nämlich am
nächsten tag direkt fertigen teig zum
plätzchenbacken ich kühl den und dann
geht es direkt los mit varianten
[Musik]
ich habe mit den fertig gekühlten teig
jetzt einfach portioniert denn ich mache
heute wirklich alle variationen und
daraus und ich habe jetzt hier 300 gramm
welchen ich gebe es euch im block aber
einfach so an als 133 rezept also mit
100 zucker 100 200 butter und 300 mail
und schreibe ich da dann die richtige
menge rein was ich jetzt zuerst mache
ich werde die erste variation machen das
sind die nubert plätzchen und dafür
werde ich jetzt hier erstmal haselnüsse
malen
dann nehme ich jetzt meinen ersten teig
knetet hier die haselnüsse unter
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr die vorher
noch in der pfanne rösten beste lecker
durften dann intensiviert sich nämlich
dass haselnuss aroma und
ihr könnt im prinzip jetzt jeden
geschmack den ihr möchtet reinbringen
also auch mandeln oder wahl musste
kokos müssen
die anderen stelle ich so man mit einem
in den schrank
hier gebe ich jetzt einfach für die
bindung noch dazu denn durch die
haselnüsse ist das ganze natürlich sieht
so ein bisschen auseinander gegangen
hier nämlich jetzt ist für die gründung
und das eiweiß brauche ich gleich zu
besprechen das ist doch schon der diese
plätze worte entwickelt sich jetzt
gerade
ich habe einfach anders gedacht denn der
junge marc nygaard und deswegen kriegt
auch schmuck platzieren
jetzt habe ich eine gute bindung fahren
das ganze zu einer rolle die etwa einen
durchmesser von 4 cm hat
[Musik]
wenn ihr die rolle und habt dann muss er
noch mal gekühlt werden ihr könnt es
einfach in folie einpacken ich nehme
hier bienenwachs tücher die könnten
nämlich wieder benutzen mussten sie
nicht wegschmeißen
und dann wird die rolle so wie sie ist
einfach eingefroren
damit sie ihre schöne form bekommt und
eben auch behält beim schneiden gleich
die keks rolle ist jetzt schon fest dass
alle frauen und jetzt nehme ich hier ein
eiweiß das gehe ich hier ein
hier habe ich jetzt gehackte nüsse
ich mache es auf dauer
wenn der teller ist rund und die rolle
ist lang
und jetzt vor
was macht sie was macht sie da
und wie gesagt bieten wachstum kann man
immer wieder verwenden die werden
einfach abgewaschen und dann sind sie
wieder einsatzbereit es wird praktisch
die rolle mit eiweiß gestrichen
und dann könnt ihr hier
einmal komplett mit den nüssen
mit dem teller schlecht geworden das hat
nicht so gut geklappt
[Musik]
unternehmt ihr euch ein schneidebrett
ein waffel brett von stoffen und
schneidet jetzt im prinzip die keks
darunter also einfach ungefähr
0,5 millimeter dicke scheiben
sie legt ihr dann auf eure parkplatz
und das hat echt coole kekse denn dafür
braucht man weder einen aus und starb
noch einen ausstecher die sind echt mega
cool die kann jeder machen
so nett für mich aufgepasst
0 5 cm natürlich fünf millimeter
und da muss ich jetzt sagen den teig
muss ich jetzt nicht mehr kühlen denn es
war eiskalt aus dem gefrierschrank also
direkt in den backofen ich mache so noch
das zweite gleich fertig denn bei
heißluft werden alle gleichzeitig
gebacken
man hat keinen keks zeitverlust man muss
nicht auf frauen die sind echt super
spiel gemacht ich finde die kann man
sogar super vorbereiten als rolle
einfrieren oder unterm jahr mein gott
also keine kekse und im jahr essen nun
muss nicht bis weihnachten warten
oder hat es jemand wer unterschreibt es
alle
die plätze sind jetzt fertig gebacken
und abgekühlt dann habe ich vor wut und
ich muss sagen dass die schmecken
schauen so schon richtig gut aber es
werden ja nur gott plätzchen und
deswegen doppeldecker ich habe jetzt
hier einfach etwas nugat in der flasche
geschmolzen ihr könnt das ganze über
wasserbad machen also ich habe es
einfach so mit der teekanne gemacht habt
es so rein gestellt so rum reingestellt
und dann gedreht dass der nutzer
praktisch nach unten fließt ihr könnt
den nougat in der mikrowelle schmelzen
also wie ihr wollt mit dem spritzbeutel
auftragen mit einem löffel mit einem
messer wie ihr möchtet und dann
praktisch zwei kekse übereinander setzen
und fertig
[Musik]
ich nenne euch your favorite
kabul ria zu den zweiten keksen und zwar
schokoladenkekse er habe ich habe wieder
meine portion teig bei den kakao keks
und eine schoko keksen könnt ihr es so
machen dass ihr entweder direkt einen
123 teig mit kakao an setzt also
praktisch bisschen mehr rauslassen dafür
cacau dazu oder ihr nehmt einfach den
fertigen teig knetet noch cacau rein es
kann aber dann sein dass er vielleicht
ein esslöffel kaltes wasser noch braucht
was ich dann zusätzlich noch dazu mache
ist tom carr banker das heißt tonkabohne
entweder nehmen wir die tonkabohnen und
treibt so ein bisschen abrieb rein ihr
könnt aber auch kaffee dazu geben wir
malen dann also wirklich wieder jeden
geschmack den ihr möchtet oder tonga
wanka direkt aus der tube praktisch
fertig portioniert zum bestreichen
nämlich dann noch ein eigelb und dann
hier noch die schokostreusel
also den tag hinein
anstand pulver dazu
und tonga dunkel
und verkneten
ich habe jetzt mal den fertigen teig
auch hier ist wieder wichtig das sollte
jetzt schön kalt sein ich werde ihn
jetzt ausrollen unternehmt ihr wirklich
immer ganz ganz wenig mehl das ist der
fehler den die meisten machen denn wenn
jetzt so viel mehl dazu geht und immer
wieder eingeredet wieder teig eben
schnell trocken tipp nummer keine ahnung
wie viel ist das ihr die plätzchen immer
gleich dick ausrollen solltet dh
entweder nimmt ihr so abstands hülse
oder in ihm gegenstände wie zum beispiel
ganz flache lego häuschen irgendwas wo
ihr wirklich rechts und links davon
legen könnt und sagen können okay der
plätzchenteig wird gleichmäßig
ausgerollt damit eben auch die backzeit
gleich ist das sind die plätze neben
gleichmäßig braun gleichmäßig durch
nichts verbrennt nicht so lawrow
entweder abstands hölzer oder ihr könnt
auch den ausruhen stab nehmen mit
abstand zwingen also da gibt es wirklich
ganz viele verschiedene möglichkeiten
ich mache jetzt die 5 mm ringe dran
auch schon
die essstäbchen benutzt also da können
wir euch wirklich mit vielen behelfen
und dann den teig schön ausräumen und
wenn er doch mal unten fest sitzt hier
vorne mail darauf streuen und mit einer
palette sozusagen das mit runterziehen
so könnt ihr wirklich mit ganz ganz
wenig mehl arbeiten
[Musik]
und jetzt sucht ihr euch einfach
ausstecher eurer wahl aus ich nehme
jetzt ihr diesen runden ausstecher und
wehrte gleich kekse machen die in der
mitte aber ein loch haben dann kann man
sie zum beispiel auch mal aufhängen oder
allgemein finde ich schon einfach recht
süß
und hier sitzt wichtig dass er gleich
große kekse immer auf einem blech packt
eben auch wegen der backzeit
und dann könnt ihr mit einer schutzhülle
oder mit einem mini aus dieser hier in
der mitte noch die kleine vertiefung
ausstechen und
ich nehme diesen mini keks und packt den
auch aber wir könnten auch einfach
nochmal verkneten und den übrigen tribe
ausstechen und da wirklich wichtig mit
hier ein bisschen mehr dran ist ein
bisschen weg steuben
zusammen kneten und wenn der teig zu
weich wird einfach noch mal kurz
gefühlen
bevor ich diese kekse jetzt allerdings
bestreichen und backe werde ich sie noch
mal kühl im gefrierschrank für etwa 15
minuten und da verlieren sie dann beim
backen ihre form nicht also ich habe
darauf achten die keks tage müssen
wirklich super kalt sein
[Musik]
die kekse sind jetzt schön gekühlt wie
ihr sehen könnt okay das kann man nicht
sehen aber ich weiß es und jetzt
bestreite ich sie an der oberfläche mit
eigelb ein bisschen vorher verrühren
und dann könnt ihr entweder
schokostreusel oder schoko blättchen
nehmen und sie mit der oberfläche
eintauchen
die kommen jetzt im backofen und sind
dann auch schon fertig wartet doch mal
richtig oben rein gekleidet kommen
gleich direkt mit runter
[Musik]
wir haben die bilder hier sarah
test meint ob du was vom ich habe
gedacht du willst einfach nur deko klar
und das jetzt den ganzen ast hier mitten
im freibad nicht gewusst
zimtschnecken plätzchen das machen wir
als nächstes das rezept gibt es
tatsächlich auf einem kanal aber ich hab
hier einfach nochmal optimiert und
vereinfacht für euch ich nehme praktisch
den hellen teil also den keks tag nicht
vorbereitet habe mach jetzt eine
zimtschnecken füllung die besteht aus
mandeln dann nehme ich jetzt diese mit
schale eiweiß braunem zucker und zimt
und das ganze wird jetzt einfach kurz
püriert ich mache das hier in der
gewürzmühle aber ihr könnt auch einfach
ein pürierstab nehmen oder direkt
einfach gemahlene mandeln das geht
natürlich auch
unter anderem mixa was er eben da hat
mit der hand
wie heißt er
chuck norris
chuck norris wird die passt natürlich
mit der hand machen
[Musik]
so sieht die füllung jetzt aus
und jetzt nehmt ihr euren teig rollt den
gleichmäßig dünn aus und zwar als
rechteck ich zeige euch auch gleich wie
am besten ungefähr drei millimeter dick
und
jetzt nutzt er sozusagen die silikon
matte
klappt zum
einmal hier
rollt hier drüber
denn dann bekommt ihr hier diese gerade
kannte
genauso andersrum
nehmen sie nur so ungefähr nicht perfekt
aber so bekommt ihr schon mal da noch
eine kante jetzt mal ist praktisch noch
einmal so und
dann habe ich ungefähr die richtung so
ein bisschen wie beim rudel teig formen
also wenn man nun tagaus rat mit der
walze faltet man den ja auch immer
wieder bis man eine schöne platte hat
und dann wird es eben in die richtige
richtung aufgerollt was soll ich mache
jetzt einfach den rest so
das passt perfekt
kompliziert die füllung drauf
[Musik]
dann schneide ich hier einmal durch und
befehle aus rolle auf rolle noch mal
schauen dass nichts an klebt und dann
schön aufrollen
[Musik]
unternehme ich hier diese rolle passt in
meinen bienenwachs tuch
zum einfrieren denn jetzt ist dennoch zu
weich
ihr könnt ja auch so ein bisschen noch
schöne form geben indem ihr das so ein
bisschen spannend
[Musik]
und dann schneidet ihr die geschnittenen
rollen einfach in 1 cm breite scheiben
legt sie aufs blech und könnte direkt
backen
[Musik]
jetzt gibt sind karten und dafür nehme
ich wieder den hellen basis teig kneten
hier zwei teelöffel zimt 1
[Musik]
die teige rolle ich jetzt 3 mm dünn aus
jetzt könnt ihr daraus karten aus
stechen mit einem eckigen ausstecher ihr
könnt sie schneiden ihr könnt sie mit
einem gewählten pizza rädchen was stumpf
ist natürlich wegen der silicon matte
ausschneiden ihr könnt ravioli schneider
nehmen ihr könnt machen was ihr möchtet
ihr könnt sie auch gerne sprache noch
strukturieren ich glaube ich den hatte
ich ja schon mal
ich glaube ich nehm rauten ich probier s
mal kurz um die ecke aus
chance oder
große raten
auch schön
na ja ich nehme dir oder
ja jetzt nämlich dieser keks struktur
stampe
fondant keks matze bahn was auch immer
struktur stempel trägt dass du ein ihr
könnt aber auch mit einer gabel zum
beispiel musste rein machen oder auch
das ganze ohne muster lassen
ich hätte auch fliesenleger werde könne
maler und tapezierer alles sauberer
schnitt kann das schön verdecken muss
so schneide ich schöne karten zu recht
[Musik]
man schlägt einfach ein lineal in die
mitte so als abstand ist jetzt keine
platzierung der produktplatzierung wäre
es
wenn ich meinen mittel start hinlegen
würde so das ist eine produktplatzierung
das ist keine denn es ist mein schuljahr
wenn es dann so diagonal darüber legt
könnt ihr nämlich schöne rauten machen
und das finde ich schön und dann werde
ich die kekse mit meiner palette direkt
aufs blech setzen nochmal kühlen damit
sie schön eiskalt sind und dann im ofen
backen und nach dem backen werden sie
direkt mit zimt zucker bestreut
weiß was ich vergessen habe ich wollte
den prägestempel den hier wollte ich
vorher in sind tauchen und dann
eintauchen
vergessen also wenn ihr möchtet für eine
extra zinsstruktur taucht ihr praktisch
diesen ausstecher oder diesem
prägestempel vorher in zimt und dann
hier rein weil dann habt ihr noch mal
vor diese braunen streifen drin
nach menschen vergessen
ich bin aber nicht
[Musik]
jetzt kann man meine lieblingsplätze
okay das hat man vielleicht oft aber
diesen die gehören schon zu mein favorit
nämlich die hilda brötchen oder auch
spitzbuben genannt oder auch
klebe plätzchen oder auch terrassen
plätzchen nämlich plätzen mit marmeladen
füllung dann nehme ich jetzt den hellen
teigrolle den gleichmäßig dünn aus
ich habe hier die kekse oder den teig
christa gesagt sie noch keine kekse den
teig auf drei millimeter ausgerollt und
jetzt nehme ich aus schlechter leyen ich
mach herzchen und zwar einen großen
einen kleinen praktisch das obendrauf
der deckel am loch bekommt und durch
loch ist bei mir hat auch ein herzchen
es stellt sich erst mal die großen
herzen aus
und hier wieder darauf achten dass der
teig schön kalt ist das heißt dann noch
mal vor dem backen einfrieren
da ist jetzt wichtig dass die kekse mit
lok und die kekse ohne loch auf zwei
verschiedenen blechen legen eben wegen
der backzeit
wenn sie dann auf einem blech legen
stehe ich hier in der mitte das loch aus
so müsste es nämlich nicht mehr weg
bewegen und das plätzchen wird nicht
zerstört
jetzt habe ich ein blech mit loch ein
blech ohne loch und die werden dann
gleich gebacken
ich habe jetzt hier meine marmelade
aufgekocht ich hab ne himbeermarmelade
ohne stückchen also fein passiert die
füllt die einen spritzbeutel
gefrierbeutel oder in die flasche
ich könnte natürlich auch mit messer auf
tragen aber ich finde dass es dann immer
mit so vielen kleinen keksen oder löffel
echt immer schwieriger und ich koche
gerne immer ein bisschen auf damit auch
so ein bisschen die feuchtigkeit
verdunstet und die so ein bisschen
fester wird
dann habe ich ziehe den deckel da wird
mit diesem schnee bestreut im vorfeld
und ein bisschen kitzeln
und dann am besten dem marmelade kurz
prüfen auf einem teller zum beispiel ob
sie gut fließt ich habe es jetzt kurz
abkühlen lassen ich habe einfach kurz
die flasche verschlossen unter kaltes
wasser und jetzt ist es nicht mehr ganz
so flüssig und ich kann damit die
unterseite sozusagen belegen
[Musik]
und dann den zweiten kicks oben drauf
setzen
[Musik]
jetzt waren wir hier noch ein paar
ausstechen kekse also ganz normale
plätzchen da darfst du mal deine formen
raussuchen und mal die sollten ungefähr
gleich groß sein damit die auch eine
gleiche backzeit haben auf einem blech
maximal noch den stern
wenn du kannst auch noch einen kleinen
machen später
ist und vielleicht auch dass so eine
blume
dabei dir
und einen tannenbaum
[Musik]
aber ich denke jetzt mal erst mal wie du
wie ein profi teig ausrollen kannst ok
also ich mache sie unter max und
bearbeiten parallelen wie partner
sozusagen
ich halte das ist ein akt zeigt dir doch
doch ich zeig dir auch warum denn wenn
ihr mit kindern ausrollt habe ziehe
nämlich schon die abstiegsränge dran
dann kann sie nämlich den teig gar nicht
erst ungleichmäßig ausrollen da habe ich
jetzt die fünf millimeter dran das passt
nicht zu dünn jetzt nehmen wir hier ganz
wenig mehr
und dann verteilt das immer so mit der
hand ja
okay
dann kriegst du hier den teig also schon
mal in den teig hinlegen und ganz wenig
mehl in die hand von normal so darüber
streichen
ja
die arbeit machen wir noch hoch so wie
bei mama ja
das haben wir kurz danach kann das sein
bist du mein kleines mini me
bist du die kleine sally
nein ist die große anlage
kenner und gucke jetzt guck mal ganz
kurz mal zu bisschen roll- und jetzt den
teig drehen
wenn er sich nicht drehen lässt du
kannst du das hier machen so
und dann wieder rollen
dann die ganze zeit
noch nicht
noch mal schon jetzt drehen wir ihn mal
so damit auch in die breite ausgerollt
wird
männer klebt wieder ein bisschen mehr
auf die oberfläche so ganz wenig aber
immer ganz ganz ganz wenig
dann gehe ich noch mal runter
einfach dass er nicht an klebt nicht wie
auch spricht man hierüber
nicht
sag mal jetzt passt perfekt jetzt ist er
super
vorbei zu deiner ausstecher
ja das ist super und dann direkt den
nächsten hier so dran setzen damit du so
viele plätzchen wie möglich aus einem
teig ausstechen kannst und die legst du
dann direkt hier drauf
stich am besten erst aus und dann nehmen
wir sie runter
aus dem gleichen tag mache ich jetzt
auch bonbons kekse
dafür rollt ihr den teig jetzt 5 mm dick
aus und dann auch ein fenster in die
mitte
[Musik]
das internet ist gelöscht das internet
ist gelöscht es gibt nie wieder netflix
youtube my little pony
was machen wir jetzt
was haben wir jetzt tun
das internet ist gelöscht
wir können jetzt auch keine videos mehr
hochladen
was machen wir jetzt
doch die können oben nicht arbeiten
gerade die von der baustelle der bagger
hat das internet zerstört
jetzt gibt es kein internet mehr auf der
welt was machen wir jetzt
das kabel zerstört
warte mal also
so war dann einfach eine bäckerei
gründen
in jeden tag packen und kekse verkaufen
aber
wenn es das nicht mehr geht
verdenken
aber was wäre die welt ohne internet das
wäre doch okay oder
ok keine videos keine videos mehr dann
müsste man halt wieder andere dinge tun
ja das ist richtig das frage ich mich
auch
aber wenn in teilen denn jetzt nicht rum
aber
aber schon gibt hier ja sturm gibt es
aber kein internet mehr
deshalb hätten gerade den mega
stromausfall alles aber geh und radweg
oder oben alle arbeitslos plötzlich aber
die leute kriegt man nicht verändert
[Musik]
was den schutz komm mal her
echt
ich habe dir nichts weg genau
diese blumen rahmen kommen jetzt bei mir
wieder in den gefrierschrank damit sie
schön fest werden oder in der
zwischenzeit werde ich schon mal bonbons
zerkleinern nämlich ganz normale bonbons
in jeglicher farbe transparenz sollten
sie sein und die werden hier dann rein
gefüllt und mit gebacken und dann habe
ich nämlich plätzchen mit einem punkt
und fenster
[Musik]
für die bonbon platzieren habe ich eine
reizende assistentin die ich hier diese
bonbons kurz da keiner wird
ihn ruhig alle
also es war jetzt bonbons mit füllung
das jetzt blöd das wusste ich jetzt auch
vorhanden dann im zweifel lieber mit
führung
bestimmt in der mitte aber keiner ohne
egal mit problem sind trotzdem das kommt
jetzt hier rein und dann kommen den
backofen und dazu läuft es nämlich und
nach dem backen müssen sie aber auf
jeden fall gut abkühlen bevor ihr sie
dann hoch nimmt
das ganze kann man übrigens auch einfach
mit isomalt machen also wenn der isomalt
daheim habt mir ein bisschen
lebensmittelfarbe einfallen oder
durchsichtig lassen
das ist mein favourit weiß bonbons
kekse ich glaube da machen wir mal so
eisprinzessin kekse
[Musik]
möchtest du vielleicht herzchen machen
wir haben noch gar keine herzchen und
gucke immer so schön nebeneinander damit
wir nicht mit dem rhein schön am rand
anfangen hier
habe ich auch von dir gar nicht anders
erwartet
wenn du die aus stehst dann halt den
ausstecher hier so oben und drückt hier
oben fest ja
[Musik]
immer mit der spitzen seite
www sterben
ja ich mich kurz
es war
ein was
ich hab kein sich
schon empfindlich da kannst du gleich
mit streusel machen
ich fühle mich neben ihrer richtung
jede idee die ich vorschlage schlägt sie
mir einfach aus können wir nicht blöd
vor
nein ich bin stift auch hier ist eine
kulisse aber nein das macht man nicht
mal stift denn den stift kann man nicht
essen
wir können strohhalm autos und was
kleines
bevor wir die backen werden die noch
eingefroren damit sie beim backen die
form behalten
und entweder kann man sie vor dem backen
mit eigelb bestreichen und mit zucker
streuseln bestreuen dann backen die
songs in mit oder man kann sie pur
backen und sozusagen nach dem backen mit
einer zitrone oder sogar glasur
bestreichen und dann bestreuen könnt ihr
dann entscheiden
das sind meine kindergartenplatz in also
die habe ich als kind im kindergarten
schon gebacken und ich glaube dass auch
die erzieherinnen mit uns das so gemacht
haben praktisch bestreichen zuckerstraße
drauf und dann rufen dann ist man fertig
denn es ist ja schon so habe ich soll in
der schule praktisch meinen schülern
erlebt dass kinder eben auch mal gerne
die finger im mund nehmen was
abschlecken und dann ist halt schon
unhygienisch wenn du praktisch nach dem
keks backen das ganze mit zitronen
puderzucker klausur machst und dann noch
mal mit streuseln weil die wenn ja dann
nicht mehr gebacken wenn es vorher
passiert um das ganze dann bei 190 grad
im backofen kommt bleibt halt nichts
mehr übrig deswegen ist das so die
perfekte keks variante mit deko die man
mit kindern machen kann auch mit fremden
kindern wollte einfach wo man echt
sichergehen dass da nix passiert dann
ist meine kindergarten kekse da freue
ich mich aufs essen
die anderen aus sicherlich hier wollen
wir mit der zitrone futter zurücklasse
machen und da habe ich jetzt einfach
foto zur grenze drohne verrührt bisschen
vanille nur ein und hier habe ich jetzt
lebensmittel verpassten und web.de noch
pastellfarben einfärben und dann können
wir die schön dekorieren okay
[Musik]
was jetzt hier noch machen wer dahinter
brötchen die hab ich ja mit dem vanille
tag gemacht ich mache aber noch hinter
brötchen mit lemon curt mein land gehört
es gibt es bereits auf einem kanal das
ist einfach eine richtig leckere
zitronencreme die ich später auch da
rein füllen werde und dafür nehme ich
dann noch eine zitrone gibt den abrieb
mit zum teil schlecht und auch die kekse
aus sowie bei dem hilder brötchen was ja
auch neben können stattdessen wer so
eine zitrone passte da ist bereits der
zitrone abrieb drin und dann hat der
keks praktisch von der zitronengeschmack
und dann habe ich später noch die
zitronen füllung halt du kannst ihn
treiben
[Musik]
hier geht das letzte drohne
guck mal ich mach jetzt noch die mit
lehman gehört und da nehme ich einfach
spritztour mit verschiedenen lokalen
größen und stellt jetzt hier praktisch
das plätzchen was oben drauf kommt damit
aus und dann kam mir die idee mein gott
ich muss mal mit einer oder mehrerer
oder beiden so kleine tier tatzen machen
weil ich so in der mitte und dann die
füße aus noch und damit magath will oder
schnee oder ach gott ach
ich sag's euch diese platz in reihe die
es gibt kein ende
es tut mir echt leid
[Musik]
das leveln gehört habe ich jetzt auch
leicht erwärmt und hier wieder in die
flasche gefüllt und jetzt kann ich hier
die unterseite der kekse damit befüllen
[Musik]
ok jetzt habt ihr kennt mittlerweile ist
schon der nächste tag
ich habe dir diese lemon cookies fertig
die zitronen cookies und werde jetzt
aber noch mit kuvertüre verschönern
dekorieren die kbc so mini spritzbeutel
da kann ich nämlich direkt weiße
kuvertüre chips beziehungsweise
kuvertüre gehackte kuvertüre einfach
schmelzen
dann soeben streifen zu einer lauten
[Musik]
also haben wir jetzt unsere plätzchen
konzert das auch probieren
sind echt viele geworden muss ich dazu
sagen also mein favorit ihn eigentlich
immer hier die hilda brötchen aber ich
glaube auch lehmann gehört wer auch und
ich hab freuen von dem mann bis den nuba
der nogat texter ist schon was isst du
aussiehst und natürlich die mit größerer
bieten habt ihr die auch genehmigt das
sind auch die mit dem bonbon in der
mitte
[Musik]
so ein tier sein stück
man muss echt sagen die schmecken am
nächsten tag immer besser so wenn sie
eine nacht durch gezogen sind und
plätzchen allgemein am besten immer
einzeln verpackt also jede sorte für
sich verpackt aufbewahren damit sich die
aromen nicht vermischen und dann ja dann
muss nur ein bisschen
ok und dann
sind nämlich mega lecker und mehrere
wochen haltbar jetzt dürft ihr gerne
eure rezepte oder die rezepte nach
machen und ausprobieren mir gerne euer
feedback geben und wie gesagt das geht
super schnell also einmal diesen großen
tag zubereitet könnt ihr auf einmal
diese plätzchen bäckerei machen und ganz
viele kekse auf einmal sauber bis bald
und viel spaß
hat euch den spaß gemacht da ich täglich
ausland nicht essen drin nach vorne hat
es dir spaß gemacht das plätzchenbacken
ja mir auch
du musst dir alle fotografieren alle
probieren und alle brück wären
und wie hält man hätte sonst könntest du
jetzt konnte nicht essen er lag kennst
du das lied in der weihnachtsbäckerei
so war es bei uns ne
da macht jemand die rollos runter ganze
klatschen da passt einfach in die rollen
doch mal was wir haben ok
[Musik]